with his dome helmet purple cloak and
fishnet covered green bodysuit
Mysterio's and instantly recognizable
supervillain but just because you can
recognize him on site doesn't mean you
know everything about the arachnid
hating trickster who's been one of
Marvel's most tenacious villains of
everyone who's ever worn Mysterio's
fishbowl helmet Quentin back created by
Steve Ditko and Stanley is by far the
most well known to save the world from
the use of technology corrupting the
human spirit
are we being punked originally a
stuntman and makeup artist who turned a
crime after getting frustrated with the
movie industry BEC first appeared an
amazing spider-man number 13 his first
step in taking down spider-man was to
impersonate the mask to webhead by using
his technological prowess to MINIX fight
his powers and frame him for various
crimes with spider-man's popularity at
an all-time low Mysterio could swoop in
as a hero when he took down spider-man
along with keeping the money he'd stolen
earlier as you'd expect
spider-man took down Mysterio and
cleared his name but Mysterio would
continue to pop up over the years
including a role as one of the original
members of the sinister six however one
of his most interesting roles came in
1980 when Beck was revealed as having
actually appeared way back in the second
issue of amazing spider-man disguised as
one of a crew of aliens and a truly
bizarre early story this helped to
establish what is arguably Mysterio's
greatest strength as a character he
could make any story work with his
mastery of illusions no matter how weird
it might get Mysterio's focus is usually
less about killing spider-man than
trying to drive him insane a cork that
shows up very early in the characters
identity in 1965 s amazing spider-man
number 24 Mysterio's dedication to the
long con is truly demonstrated when dr.
Ludvik Reinhardt arrives at the Daily
Bugle making a compelling case that
spider-man is a hair's breadth away from
complete insanity Spidey shrugs it off
at first but when he begins to see his
arch villains crawling out of the walls
to attack him before disappearing in
smoke he's
a bit more convinced he pays dr.
Rhinehart a visit to see if he can get
some help but the hallucinations get so
bad that spider-man gets one step away
from revealing his secret identity
fortunately Daily Bugle boss Jay jonah
Jameson bursts in to accuse the
not-so-good doctor of being a fraud with
his mind clear
Spidey quickly defeats dr. Rhinehart and
discovers as you might expect but it's
actually Quentin back in disguise while
Becks plan wasn't successful it
established his modus operandi early on
Mysterio could never beat spider-man in
a fair fight so he uses deception to
drive the wall crawler to defeat himself
another notable attempt at getting
Spidey to crack came in 1992 s web of
Spiderman number 90 in the issue
spider-man finds himself taking on the
world devouring Galactus and wakes up
afterwards to discover that he's a
card-carrying a list celebrity who's
been enjoying the good life ever since
his brief stint in the wrestling ring
against crusher Hogan an event that
happened way back in his very first
appearance something's amiss on the set
of his newest feature Phil when some of
his toughest villains attack after
dispatching Hobgoblin and venom Spidey
figures out what's really going on
Mysterio hired Mack Schiffman to help
him construct an entire alternate life
for spider-man to get trapped in while
the plot is classic Mysterio the issue
is notable for an additional wrinkle
that it provides - Mysterio's character
while fighting spider-man Mysterio
disguised as venom reveals that when his
helmet was cracked during their first
fight it exposed Quentin to the
hallucinogenic mists that lets him
control illusions with his exposure to
the mists his own grasp on reality was
shattered leaving him unable to tell
illusion from reality it's an
interesting idea but it's only
occasionally been revisited since the
Marvel Universe has always been
connected the very first issue of
amazing spider-man has him dropping by
to hassle the Fantastic Four and Spidey
and daredevil in particular have an
especially long bad guy exchange program
the kingpin Daredevils greatest and most
well
archenemy was originally a spider-man
villain and the AL electro and of course
Mysterio have all jumped back and forth
between the heroes in Guardian devil a
1998 arc of daredevil written by
filmmaker Kevin Smith and drawn by
future Marvel editor-in-chief Joe
Quesada daredevil wrestles with the
responsibility of taking care of a child
that seems to either be the messiah or
the Antichrist however after a quick
consultation with dr. strange and
Mephisto the actual literal devil in the
Marvel Universe he realizes that he's
been drugged and that the baby is just a
baby Mysterio newly diagnosed with lung
cancer and an inoperable brain tumor
from his years of getting high off of
his own a loose energetic supply had
enacted a grand revenge scheme against
his second most hated foe once the trick
was revealed Mysterio was hopeful that
daredevil would kill him once that
failed Mysterio took care of the matter
himself in a death that spelled the end
for Quentin Beck's run as Mysterio for a
while while there are other people who
have worn the Mysterio mantle in the
main Marvel Universe also known as
earth-616 there is another version worth
mentioning the Mysterio of the ultimate
universe while other characters would
get a complete top to down reimagining
for Marvel's rebooted ultimate comics
the ultimate version of Mysterio wasn't
all that different from the 6-1-6
version he first showed up an ultimate
spider-man annual number three and his
biggest difference from his 6-1-6
counterpart was that he had a worse
costume while some would find fault with
a fishnet covered green body suit and a
fishbowl helmet you can't argue that it
isn't immediately recognizable the
ultimate version of Mysterio had none of
his predecessors Flair using only a
boring ghost-like effect over his face
as a disguise as it turns out though
there was a reason that the ultimate
Mysterio wasn't all that different from
the 6-1-6 version in a truly weird plot
twist it was eventually revealed that
they weren't actually two characters at
all instead the ultimate Mysterio was a
ridiculously high-tech
Android piloted across the universes by
the 6-1-6 Mysterio in order to
accomplish the same kinds of crimes that
he got up to in his home universe no
really
it happened in spider-man a series where
the core universes Peter Parker traveled
across dimensions to mentor the ultimate
universes new spider-man Miles Morales
if that's all sounding just a bit
familiar it's because the plot was
loosely adapted for 2018 into the
spider-verse motion picture along with a
couple of other cross-dimensional
spider-man stories spider-man ended with
Mysterio in custody in the Ultimate
Universe leaving the role of Mysterio to
be filled by other lesser criminal
geniuses Quentin Beck is the original
but he's not the only Mysterio an
amazing spider-man number 141 Daniel
Burkhardt appears as a stunt man who
took over for Beth who had faked his own
death at the time while it's hard for
any villainous replacement to surpass
the original Burkhardt was less notable
than most and never really had a unique
spin on the Mysterio identity his most
well known stories involved him
pretending to be a resurrected Quentin
back in order to torment spider-man when
your best-known plot involves pretending
to be a more beloved character and
generally succeeding you're not really
going to last long in a comic book
universe even when he got title billing
in his own miniseries spider-man the
Mysterio manifesto he spent most of the
story dressed as an entirely different
second-string supervillain
jack-o'-lantern spooky created by
Rachael and Terry Dotson and Kevin Smith
and spider-man black cat the evil that
men do francis clumb is arguably the
worst Mysterio
unlike others klom actually has
superpowers he's a mutant with the
ability to teleport along with some
assorted telepathy and telekinesis a
complicated series of events clumb ended
up accidentally getting knocked off a
bridge by spider-man which led to clumb
losing part of his leg and naturally
this led him to embark on crusade of
vengeance against spider-man dressed as
one of his old enemies his crusade of
vengeance didn't last long though he was
interrupted by both Bek and Burkhardt
who were not happy about gimmick
infringement even worse for qualms he
was eventually stabbed in the chest by
thousands of spiders wearing the form of
a school nurse bats comics baby while
Burkhardt and clumb popped over to cover
for Bek while he was dead who fought
spider-man while Bek was stuck in the
ultimate universe after the events of
spider-man a brand-new character named
mysterion created by David Lopez and
Christopher Yost an amazing spider-man
number 22 which was the twenty-third
issue because you know what just forget
it
comics am i right anyway mysterion was
well basically the same as previous
Mysterio's except not quite as competent
in the issue he picks up the costume and
gear from Hobgoblin before running afoul
of both the Punisher who kills
supervillains and the superior
spider-man a Spider Man with the soul of
Doctor Octopus who also kills
supervillains somewhat surprisingly he
actually managed to survive the
encounter and popped up a couple of more
times in the Marvel Universe most
notably when he took on the unbeatable
Squirrel Girl and all of the Avengers
with robot dinosaurs unfortunately
without an actual name or defining
features were unlikely to see much of
mysterion going forward considering how
closely his power set aligns with movie
magic you would have expected Mysterio
to make an appearance in a cinematic
spider-man adaptation long before 2019
spider-man far from home as it turns out
he quite nearly did
Geoffrey Henderson a storyboard artist
who worked with Sam Raimi on the
original spider-man trilogy reveal
that a planned spider-man 4 would have
included Mysterio along with a handful
of other spider foes originally the idea
was to run through lower tier villains
like the Shocker the Prowler rhino stilt
man and of course Mysterio since they
figured they would never be chosen as
the main antagonists of other films as
for who would portray the master of
illusions in the quick cameo Henderson
suggested that Bruce Campbell a longtime
Sam Raimi collaborator who had made
brief cameos in all of the previous
spider-man movies good step beneath the
bowl to play Quentin Beck it never
happened but it's hard not to be
intrigued by what the scenery-chewing
campbell could have done with one of
Mysterio's many monologues romance I am
French it took him a long time to get
his big screen do but Mysterio finally
made the jump to theaters courtesy of
Jake Gyllenhaal's portrayal in 2019
spider-man far from home in some ways
his long journey to the big screen is a
good thing with the huge advances in CGI
and special effects technology made in
the last couple of decades there's
arguably no better time for a super
villain to harness the lifelike
illusions and movie magic trickery of
Mysterio Plus given Gyllenhaal's deeply
unsettling portrayal of an amoral
psychopath in 2014's Nightcrawler it's
almost guaranteed that the villain will
be just as creepy and unsettling as his
best stories make him out to be here's
hoping this latest incarnation of this
enduring Marvel character ends up
sticking around for more than a single
outing and signals a future in which the
MCU villains only get weirder and wilder
check out our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]